morning guys how are we why am I here to
build a kitchen and to get a production
going and give you guys a chance to earn
and learn and put back inside
he's our Grafton it is public Grafton
yeah it's proper graft listen let's be
honest you get out of it we put into it
good question ready 20 years ago I got
dealt a dysfunctional cars
my little brother became a heroin addict
and my father became an alcoholic what
do I do
do I sit there enjoy my little brother
or I'll become an alcoholic alongside my
father no I got my ass I stopped for
feeling sorry for myself and I got on
with it put my head down learn the craft
and that's the journey I'm hoping that
we're gonna go on thank you I think he
paid it well because he's he's told us a
bit about himself he's history how he
how he became a cook and you know he's
told us about his family I have less
than six months to kick this motley crew
into shape
and try and mold them into a kitchen
outfit that can pay its way but can any
of them even cook a simple dish of
scrambled eggs and a spot any talent
here
little toss little plate of scrambled
eggs please a burglar Anthony Kelly age
33 is a career criminal
having spent half his life in and ten
years last time a schematic nice you
getting romantic now he's 45 now last
month so yeah 25 years no you're kidding
me
yeah seems like at work yeah bubbles 90
minutes cooking's 125 hours of prime
know text
she's trusting me
if it is an omelette been what it be all
right
designs range from disastrous nothing's
gonna go inside the bag
to the delectable